hi everyone my name is Eric Richard
Kazuki I'm a partner here at YC I
actually started a company that went
through Y Combinator back in 2011 I
started a company called pebble we made
one of the first smartwatches I am
really excited to be here to talk about
talking to users because this is one of
the perennial things that that you
always hear about as one of the critical
factors in starting a company the best
founders maintain a direct connection to
their users throughout the lifespan of
their entire company they maintain a
direct connection because they need to
extract information from from their
users at all different stages of running
their company often times people think
that you know they're the CEO or they're
the CTO they're the technical kind of
product leads of the company they can
outsource this this that they can
outsource this research to other people
in their company they can hire
salespeople they can hire heads of
product but at the core the best
companies are the ones where the
founders themselves maintain a direct
connection to their users if you are the
CEO it is your job it is in your job
description to talk to customers so take
the time to learn how to do it well all
founders need to need to participate in
this process as well don't if you're the
engineer if you're the developer don't
think that you can escape this process
just because you're the person who's
coding there's a pretty classic scene
from the movie office space where they
there's an individual who says I'm the
person who who is the go-between between
engineers and users I know how to talk
to people I have people skills and that
is one of the things that you do not
want to have happen at your company you
want to make sure that the founders and
the the the core the core members of
your company are the ones who develop
the skills for talking to users so you
do not have to hire someone like that to
be the go-between talking to users is so
critical that at the core of kind of ycs
teachings there are only two things that
you must do in order to search your
company you need to code or
build your product and talk to users so
this is easier said than done I want to
provide today some tactical advice on
how to plan your strategy for talking to
users as well as some some questions and
strategies that you can use to conduct
your own user interviews at the
beginning of your of your company a lot
of the advice that I that I'll present
today is actually synthesized
fantastically in this book actually
written by a YC founder called the mom
test the name of the book comes after
kind of the the process in which we
probably all go through where we want to
tell our parents about the company that
we're working on and we I think that by
talking to people that you know love us
and want to support us
we're actually extracting good or useful
information about how to how we could
adjust or improve our company but at its
core this is not the best way to get
information so the mom test as Rob
actually explains it's three common
errors that we make when we try to
preach I to conduct user interviews the
first problem the first mistake that we
pretty much all make is we talk about
our idea we're founders we love to pitch
our idea we love to talk about the the
product that we're working on but during
a user interview that is not the time to
be pitching the product the goal of a
great user interview is to extract
information from the person that you're
talking to to extract data that will
help you improve the product or improve
your marketing or improve your
positioning it is not to sell them on
using your product so at the core of a
great injury user interview you need to
learn about their life you need to talk
about specifics around the problem area
that you're trying to solve that the
user may be going through second mistake
that we pretty much all make is we talk
about hypotheticals we talk about what
our product could be we talk about
features that we want to build we ask
questions like we ask questions like if
we built this feature would you be
interested in using it
would you be interested in paying for it
that is wrong instead talk about
specifics that have already occurred in
the users life this will give you
stronger and better information in which
to make product and company changing
decisions you also want to talk in
general about the users life you don't
want to just talk about the specific
problem or sorry the the specific
solution that you're presenting try to
extract information about the users the
path that led them to encounter that
problem ask them questions about their
life in kind of more broader and more
broader ways to extract context around
how they arrived at this at this problem
learn about their motivations learn
about why they got themselves into that
problem in the first place and the third
trap that we pretty much all fall into
is that we talk we talk a lot or
founders we're always pitching investors
were pitching employees we're trying to
hire people we're trying to partner so
we tend to spend a lot of our time
talking in a user interview try to try
to restrain your your your interest in
talking and really listen take notes and
listen to what the user is saying
because in that span of time that 10 20
30 minutes that you spend with the user
you're trying to extract as much
information as possible so that when you
return to the office and when you return
to your co-founders you're bringing hard
data real facts about users lives to the
table I think that there are five great
questions that everyone can ask during
their their early customer interviews
the first question is what is the
hardest part about doing the thing that
you're trying to solve
let's take Dropbox for an example now
many of you may not remember our world
before Dropbox but put yourself back in
the position of Drew the founder of
Dropbox in 2005 when he was initially
working on kind of the the initial idea
of Dropbox while working while studying
at MIT imagine you're in the computer
lab at MIT and you're sitting next to
your friend you turn and you ask you're
working on this project to create
Dropbox and you
you want to learn more about how other
people are sharing files so that you can
learn you know are these other potential
users here or what are the problems that
I can help solve with this new
technology so you turn to your friend
and you ask what is the hardest part
about working on a group project with
school computers you're sending in the
computer lab it's the perfect context
for asking that kind of question and you
begin open-ended conversation trying to
extract information about how that
person currently works on group projects
together with friends hopefully you'll
learn about specific pain points that
they have like they log on to a shared
computer they have to get their files
from somewhere they may have a network
drive attached to the the university
system but they're working with someone
who may not be logged on to a university
computer at that time maybe you learn
about problems with synchronizing of
shared work maybe you're both working on
the exact same document at the exact
same time how do you begin how do you
currently attempt to solve that problem
in general the best startups are looking
for problems that people face on a
regular basis or that they're painful
enough to warrant solving this question
can help confirm or or confirm for you
whether the problem that you're actually
working the the problem that you're
working on is actually one that real
users feel is a pain feel as something
that they actively want to solve in
their life the second question to the
point that I was making earlier about
trying to get to specifics rather than
hypotheticals is to ask the question
tell me about the last time that you
encountered this problem the goal of
this question is actually to extract
context around the circumstances in
which the user encountered that problem
so for example in the Dropbox case you
may be talking to your friend and learn
about a week ago a specific time frame
who were they working with which which
which which class were they working
working on which was this it was it's a
computer science problem was this a an
English paper try to extract as much
information as you
and about the the context in which they
began solving this problem so that as
you develop as you develop your product
you'll be able to actually reference
real-life examples of past problems that
potential users have had and you can
overlay your solution on top of that to
see if it would have helped in that
particular circumstance the third
question is why was this hard
why was the circumstance in which that
student was trying to work on their
their shared project their their project
with other folks why was that hard what
were these specific things that they
encountered that were difficult the
reason why you want to ask this question
is because you'll hear many different
things from different people going back
to the Dropbox example you might
encounter some people who say that maybe
the problem may be the number one
problem that they were encountering was
when they emailed files back and forth
they ended up duplicating work because
they didn't have the exact same kind of
document at the exact same time maybe
other people will say that they
submitted the wrong document in the end
to the to the professor for their group
project because they had like crazy
strings of file version numbers on the
end so the benefit from asking this
question is not just to identify the
exact problem that you may begin to
solve with your solution to this problem
but you'll also begin to understand how
you market your product how you explain
to new potential users the value or the
benefits of of your solution in general
customers don't buy what they don't buy
the what they buy the why so in the
Dropbox example they may not be they may
not be excited and overjoyed at saying
oh I now have this kind of file syncing
tool that can that can keep all my files
in sync but they'll by the Y they'll say
well this exact product this product
will help with this exact problem that I
had just two weeks ago when I was trying
to work on a student project with some
of my friends so answers that you get
from customers to this question of why
why was this past problem that you
encountered so hard
may actually inform your marketing or
your sales copy as you as you build out
the rest of your product fourth question
is what if anything have you done to try
to solve this problem one of the biggest
things that that I've encountered well
while helping YC companies over the last
few years is that if customers if
potential customers are not already
exploring potential solutions to their
problem it's possible that the problem
that you're trying to solve is not a
burning enough problem for customers for
them to be even interested in your
better solution to this product so this
question tries to get at the root of
that of that of that issue is the person
who encounters this problem already
trying to solve this so in the Dropbox
example you're working on a group
project or you're talking to someone
who's who's worked on group projects in
the past try to figure out what what
tools did they experiment with what
tools did they try to use to solve this
in the past maybe they they solve this
by getting all the individuals together
in one room to work on the project with
four computers so that they could talk
in real-time to to each other as they
were working on the project maybe they
maybe they experimented with email maybe
they tried setting up as one of the top
comments on Hacker News posted during
the original Dropbox launch maybe they
had set up our sink and they would
already solve this problem with SFTP or
something like that again you want to
ask this question for two reasons one is
to figure out whether the problem that
you're solving or you're working to
solve is even really something that
people are already looking for solutions
to you and the second one is what are
the other competition out there
what will your product be compared
against as you as you as you end up
rolling out your solution and offering
it to end customers the fifth question
is very tactical so what don't you love
about the solutions that you've already
tried this is the beginning of your
potential feature set this is how you
ask the or this is how you begin
understanding
what the features are that you'll build
out for your better solution to the
problem now note that this is not the
question of what features would you want
out of a new file syncing product in the
Dropbox example because that's a
hypothetical question users in general
are not great at identifying the the
next features that they want in the
product just like the old you know Henry
Ford quote you know our when we were
developing the automobile or our users
would have wanted a faster horse rather
than that car so this question
specifically targets what are the what
are the what are the problems with the
existing solutions that they've already
tried these are these are specifics and
you can begin to kind of figure out what
the diff the differential between your
new solution and the existing solutions
already in the market will be talking to
users as I said before is useful I
pretty much all stages of your company
but there's three critical phases to an
early-stage company I would kind of
define that as a company that has not
yet reached product market fit in which
talking to users would be extremely
beneficial those three stages are at the
idea stage before you've even begun
developing any any of your product at
the prototype stage where you have the
first kind of rough beginnings of your
product but you haven't really gotten in
the hands of any paying customers or any
users yet and the third one which is
after you've launched and you're
iterating towards product market fit how
do you guide that journey so I'll talk
about a few tips for for each phase at
the idea stage you may have the back of
a napkin idea you may have a thought may
or may be you may be commercializing
some technology that you've been
dreaming of but you don't yet have any
first users so you need to begin finding
the first people that will be interested
in either providing information about
the problem that they've encountered or
potentially signing up to be your first
users the best the best
you know people come to come to me to
ask how can i how can i talk and how can
i find my first users honestly some of
the best companies are
products or services that are built for
the founders themself so start with
yourself begin like test test your user
interview strategy on yourself try to
walk through a situation where you've
encountered that problem the next step
after that is to talk to friends is to
talk to co-workers to get warm
introductions
it doesn't take a lot of people you
don't have to talk to thousands of
people you every good user kind of
research strategy begins with just one
or two people the critical the critical
feature here is executing a unbiased and
and detailed customer or user interview
strategy rather than just trying to to
pitch your idea to them
another cool hack that that we've seen
some great success with actually a YC
company in this batch is using this - a
YC company this batch is actually
selling selling products to firefighters
and they realized that cold email
introductions was just not working was
not a way that they could get through to
the customers so what they did was they
actually just dropped by fire stations
in person they didn't even you know
email them to say that they were coming
ahead of time they just showed up and
they said hey could we speak to the fire
chief could we talk to someone about
this problem that were that we've got a
solution to and you know what it worked
great they managed to get dozens of
in-person no 10 to 15-minute long
meetings just by showing up so when in
doubt if there's a specific target
customer base that you're looking to get
feedback from just try showing up never
it feels a little bit weird because it
feels like you're imposing on someone
but at the end of the day the mindset
that I like to get into is if you truly
think that you're solving a problem that
your target customer base is facing
you'll actually be doing them ahead
you'll be helping them out by taking
their 15 minutes and and learning more
about the problem industry events are
another great way to get a number of new
customer interactions I remember that
when I was working on pebble we actually
went to CES which is this large consumer
electronics show in Vegas we didn't have
a booth
we just went in guerilla-style we just
like randomly started setting up in
setting up meetings with potential users
and we met them in like the coffee shop
I would side at the conference we did
that for $0 without any sort of
marketing budget just because that was
where a lot of people in the industry
were and we knew that there was like a
high concentration of potential people
that we could talk to some tips for this
stage take notes take detailed notes
because like I said before you don't
you'll never know until later which key
facts of these user interviews may be
useful if you're not great at taking
notes while you're talking to someone
bring a friend bring a co-founder ask
the person if you could record it
when in doubt capture as much
information as possible keep it casual
like I said before you can just show up
you don't have to like pre-planned this
you don't have to have you know 20
minute blocks on your calendar scheduled
for days on end of user interviews
feel free to react like honestly you'll
learn so much through the first 5 or 10
user interviews that you know you'll
your your process will dramatically
improve from those first interviews to
the next batch so don't feel like you
have to do a hundred user interviews all
at the same time just start with one
start with three start with five until
you get the hang of it the third thing
is you need to be cognizant of the other
person's time again going back to what I
said at the beginning you know we love
our idea we're founders we love talking
about our idea so you need to you need
to keep yourself in check and make sure
that you're cognizant to the other
person's time honestly you'll be able to
get probably the best information out of
say a ten to fifteen minute long first
interview and that might be all the time
you need just just for that initial chat
as you move past the ideas stage into
testing your your prototype with users
the next major kind of benefit that you
can that you can get from talking to
users is figuring out who will be your
best first customer this is critical
because it's possible that if you choose
the wrong first customer that you may be
led down a path that that constrains you
or artificially traps you without
actually getting paid by that first
customer so we've created a framework
that you can use to begin to identify
before you begin working with them who
the best first customers will be during
user interviews at this stage I love to
to ask questions that extract numerical
answers to three facts about the
customer that I'm working with the first
one that I like to get that I want to
get to the bottom of is how much does
this problem cost them today and I like
to get a hard number either in terms of
how much revenue do they stand to earn
if they solve this problem or how much
how much expense do they currently spend
trying to solve this problem how much
money is wasted today as they try to
solve this problem second one that I
like to get to the bottom of is how
frequently do they encounter this
problem do they encounter it on hourly
basis a daily basis quarterly basis
yearly basis the best the best problems
that startups can can target are ones
that are encountered more frequently
this is usually beneficial for two
reasons one is they encounter a problem
on a more regular basis it means that
the customers feeling the pain of that
problem on a more regular basis and
they'll be much more receptive to a
potential solution the second reason why
you want to tackle a problem that people
encounter on a more frequent basis is
you'll get more chances to know whether
your product is actually solving a
problem in my case with pebble I love
the fact that I was working on a device
that was kind of intended to be used
every day you know you wake up in the
morning you put your watch on that was
great for me because I knew that if they
weren't if users weren't wearing their
watch on a regular basis that meant that
I was doing something wrong so the best
first customers are ones that have this
problem very frequently the third thing
that you want to get to the bottom of is
how large is their budget for solving
this problem you can imagine that say
you're solving something for an
industrial assembly line problem on the
industrial assembly line if you're
talking to the operator the person who's
actually there on the kind of the
assembly line they may encounter this
problem on a really regular basis
but they just don't have the budget
they don't have the authority to
actually solve the problem that's their
boss so that's someone above them in the
in the office of in the headquarters so
again as you're trying to identify the
best first customers make sure that
you're trying to that make sure that
you're asking questions about whether
they actually have the ability to solve
the problem given the choice I like to
visualize answers to these to these
three sets of customer questions as
overlapping Venn diagrams with the best
first customer being at the center of
the Venn diagram where they have the
highest kind of numerical answers to the
three questions that I outlined so let's
take a quick example imagine if you're
working on like a super smart blender
that's designed to produce the the
tastiest new fruit smoothies you talked
to several users let's say you're
talking to McDonald's the French Laundry
and the Google cafe you create a
spreadsheet that simply has three
columns with the answers to the
questions that you've extracted through
your user interviews via this data can
actually be used in prioritizing which
customer you you begin to sell your
product to first so for example the
French Laundry is an amazing restaurant
up in Napa
maybe maybe they have an opportunity to
to roll out a new extremely fancy
over-the-top smoothie with your new
technology they can extract a lot of a
lot of money from each sale but the
frequency is not that high there's just
not that many customers that are
interested in a fruit smoothie at the
French Laundry and you're talking to
maybe the the sous-chef at the at the
restaurants so you realize that they
don't really have that much money to
solve this problem even if they wanted
to the other the other potential
customer that you're talking to is the
chef at one of the Google cafes
unfortunately for you Google gives away
their food for free to their employees
so that person doesn't actually stand to
earn more money or save that much more
money if they were to use your new
smoothie technology in their in their
restaurant granted there are a lot of
Googlers so there probably would be a
lot of smoothies made per week but at
the same time again you know they just
don't have the budget to be able to to
really dig into this problem so you
learn through the initial customer
interviews that McDonald's is actually
the best potential customer AB attention
potential first customer for your
product while even though the the the
cost of a new smoothie at McDonald's may
not bring in you know a large dollar
amount per transaction they have a ton
of stores and each of those stores
services a ton of people and on top of
that you happen to get a warm
introduction to the like chief food
officer of McDonald's which I'm not even
sure they have but that person actually
controls like a multi-billion dollar
budget and if they wanted to solve this
problem they would have the authority
and they would have the the budget to do
so and so you put that information in
your spreadsheet and you actually do
like a simple stack rank that just pulls
the best answers to those questions up
to the top and you can use this
framework for for kind of pulling
together all the information that you
get from various user surveys to to find
the best customers the last stage a four
product market fit that can benefit from
user interviews is actually the process
of iterating towards product market fit
Paul Graham's cut definition for product
market fit is when you've made something
that people want Marc Andreessen also
has an amazing blog post about product
market fit where he describes it as when
the product is just being pulled out of
you when you no longer have to push the
product on customers they're just
pulling it pulling it from you but the
problem with these definitions of
product market fit is that they're vague
they're also retroactive in that you
have to already have product market fit
in order to know that you've reached it
so they're not as useful for helping you
figure out which features you can use
which features you need to build in
order to iterate in order to improve
your product to get to product market
fit you may have heard of the app
superhuman which is a super fast email
client well the CEO published an amazing
blog post a little while ago about how
he built a well how he was actually
annoyed with this a vague definition of
what product market fit is and how it
was a lagging indicator that didn't help
him predict product market fit had only
told him whether he achieved it or not
he wanted to create a real-time
quantitative system that had that had
helped guide his company towards product
market fit and of course it involved
talking to users he wrote a great blog
post on this you could just google it I
would just gonna touch her kind of touch
on it but I would highly recommend
reading the entire thing because it is
it is fantastic but in it he describes a
process where on a weekly basis
he asks pretty much all his customers
but it doesn't even have to be your
entire customer base it could just be
you know 30 40 users a critical question
how would you feel if you could no
longer use superhuman three answers very
disappointed somewhat disappointed not
disappointed he measured the percentage
of users who answered the question very
disappointed
these are the users who most value your
product this is these are the users who
your product has now become a key part
of their life it's kind of weaseled
their way into their daily habits he
read some analysis that said that a 40
percent or more of your user base
reports that they would be very
disappointed if your product went away
on a weekly basis that that's kind of
the signal that's the the
differentiation point that it says if
you get past this point your product
will just grow exponentially and he
evaluated a number of other successful
companies and realized that the answer
to this question was always around or
above 40 percent so again I probably
won't be able to go into it too much
more in detail but I would recommend
reading this blog post if you're at the
stage where you're iterating and you
actively have users that you can ask
this question of this can be an
immensely useful thing for
quantitatively determining whether the
features that you worked on in the
previous week we're actually benefiting
or adding to your product market fit or
potentially detracting from it as well
some other great tips that we found at
this stage is kind of a simple hack ask
your users for the phone number during
signup because oftentimes you'll be
looking at the data and you'll be
wondering you know why did why is the
data showing this particular
kind of learning about our customers and
you maybe like thinking and aggregate
like you know 20% of people have this
problem sometimes it helps to just get
on the phone and talk to one person
who's encountering this problem so I
always encourage founders to put contact
to put contact information including
phone number which is like a direct
connection to customers pretty high up
in the user signup flow second one is
don't design by committee you can't
simply ask your users what features they
want you have to begin to understand
whether those features are truly going
to going to help make your product more
sticky and more useful you can do this
through kind of the the advice of the
superhuman CEO lays out in his blog post
or you could ask other tactical
questions like instead of asking you
know do Tweel users be interested in
using this new product or this new
feature instead say here's us here's an
upgrade flow if you want this new
product put your credit card or if you
want this new feature put your credit
card information or pay more even before
you actually built out the feature this
could help give you information about
whether the feature that you're working
on it's actually something that the
users are going to use the third thing
to do during user interviews at this
stage is to remember to discard bad data
some of the some of the kind of worst
bad data that you may encounter is
compliments people may say oh I love the
new design or man this thing is really
useful you may love that during the
course of user interviews but they
actually are not useful information
because it's not specific it's more of a
general statement about your product and
it's not tactical it's not giving you
correct information on what you can
change or what you can improve about
you're um you're probably the second
main type of bad data that you may
encounter is fluff they're hypotheticals
these are generation Eric statements
whenever you're in the middle of a user
interview and you start getting onto
onto this hypothetical you know oh
here's what it here's what the product
may look like in the future try to steer
it back to specifics again you're
conducting a user interview not to pitch
your product but to learn about problems
or the issues that the user has faced in
their past so that you can improve it in
the future
that's it that was meant to be like a
quick quick short dive into talking
talking to users I don't know if we have
any time for questions
cool awesome I'd love to answer any
questions but other than that thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
you